joining us now to discuss some solutions
to the teacher shortages Australia's
most famous and enthusiastic math
teacher Eddie
oh my God
thank you never gets old sorry I don't
know what came about for me then um but
I'm very excited to talk to you about
this because I think you'll have unique
Insight actually there are thousands of
teacher vacancies across Australia still
how do we fill them yeah look first
thanks for starting me off on a really
nice gentle easy question I guess it's
really important to acknowledge that
there just is no Silver Bullet solution
to this problem right because if one
existed then I wouldn't have become a
maths teacher you know 20 years ago
because it was that shortage that you
refer to which is what drove me into
teaching mathematics rather than some of
the other subjects where we have more
abundant teachers so when we talk about
society as a whole being able to address
the attitude towards teaching it's still
not a profession which has a lot of
respect or or dignity or value in
society when we talk about you know
we've got a new government coming in
being able to put out money where our
mouth is when it comes to addressing
some of the challenges the workforce um
working conditions all these issues play
into it in terms of retention of
teachers because actually we don't have
that much trouble convincing people to
come into the profession because it's
Noble and there's a great moral purpose
to it but actually keeping them there
that's the hard part A pay rise would
help as well though right look I'm not
going to complain if someone you know it
changes the award but of course that's
what I'm going to say right
teachers need to be paid well because
it's important work that you're doing um
Eddie we know that there is a huge
shortage as well of male teachers in
particular how do we then make the
profession more attractive to blokes I
think more than ever our young people in
schools need fantastic mail role models
and lots of them I think it's important
to recognize that obviously teaching is
definitely a caring profession you won't
get anywhere as a teacher if you don't
care about your students but it's not
only a caring profession which tends to
be dominated by women it's also a
profession where we are actually
tackling really big purposeful problems
that affect all of society and that sort
of problem-solving angle on it I think
that's one of the things that resonates
with a lot of men and maybe emphasizing
that as part of what it means to be a
teacher to solve problems that matter to
everyone would actually help us restore
some of that balance you talk about well
Eddie maybe the answer is picking up a
little side hustle potentially which is
what you've just done I've just found
out you now the University of Sydney's
professor of practice what does that
mean what are you practicing yeah it's
for me a really exciting opportunity to
work with pre-service teachers because
what we want to do is help those
students who are becoming teachers to be
exposed to the realities of everyday
classrooms it's really worthwhile work
but it's also challenging and we don't
want to disguise any of those
difficulties for them we want them going
in with both their eyes open being
prepared and having really practical
authentic and current expertise to teach
them how to teach to help their students
be the best Learners they can be
we need help with our homework here
there's a math problem that has left the
entire internet stumped can you help us
solve this I'm just going to anticipate
that there are a few different opinions
for people who are maybe watching your
home or maybe even there in the studio
with you lots of people are thinking
maybe it's uh two times one plus two is
six so six divided by six gives you one
which I think is what you mentioned but
other people are going to argue and say
no no hold up 6 divided by two that's
three and then you multiply that by one
plus two which is three yes you get nine
so is the answer one or nine and you
might hate me for a second but I'm going
to say the answer is
yes because what's yes this was actually
a mathematical equation that get me
right it was designed to be ambiguous
you might not like that but it's a bit
of a gotcha kind of problem it's meant
to trick you it's a mathematical
sentence a little bit like I saw a man
with a telescope now you tell me did you
see a man walking by and he was holding
a telescope in his hand or did you look
through a telescope and see a man I saw
a man with a telescope is ambiguous and
maths can be like that sometimes too so
one or nine they're kind of both the
answer oh Eddie we love chatting with
you thank you so much for your time
tonight
foreign